it's been wonderful this week to be here
at Davos to attend the World Economic
Forum I think it's a very good way for
CMU to showcase its successes and
accomplishments it's also an opportunity
to learn from our colleagues from other
institutions and also people from
industry and government there a number
of interactions that we had individually
with the presidents of other
universities heads of industry alumni of
CMU who have done very well as CEOs so
it's the opportunity to network to
connect with people to get feedback and
to get some new ideas on what we could
do to engage both locally within the CMU
campuses but also globally this week we
had a CMU ideas lab on the concept of
learning outcomes this is based on
something called the Simon initiative
that we launched just a couple of months
ago it involves CMU's unique role in
creating new platforms new methods and
tools to impact learning outcomes for K
through 12 for undergraduate students
and indeed for lifelong learning I think
CMU's greater contribution is going to
read widen the public's increasing
awareness of technology and education to
start to think about outcomes and how we
can change outcomes not just access we
don't start with technology we start
with the science of learning that was
abundantly clear today and it was also
abundantly clear how much that's needed
in the national and international
dialogue around technology enhanced
learning 10 to 20 years from now we're
going to see in impact of carnegie
mellon in terms of convincing
educational institutions that they can
make research a regular part of what
they do that you know we do just don't
make it up when we go into the classroom
that we can design instruction using
science and we'll look back and say
carnegie mellon really help make that
happen as a graduate of carnegie mellon
i find it quite heartening to find that
the school has a very large presence
here at Davos there aren't lots of
schools here there are a few
the most prestigious in the in the world
of which Carnegie Mellon is one of us we
have initiated conversations about
collaborations between CMU and
institutions in Europe and in Asia I
look forward to following up on many of
the things that have happened here in da
was this week
you